[Music]
all right awesome so we're back with
another stream
my grandmaster's choice and today's
theme is going to be prophylaxis and
Dynamics so
prophylaxis is often thought about as
something positional and I don't know if
everyone has
if everyone knows what prophylaxis means
but the idea is generally to prevent
your opponent's ideas so it's a
complicated idea I would say and it's
mostly
undervalued but
I would like to give some examples from
my practice
to sort of give some ideas of how you
can prevent your opponent's play while
improving your position it's very
underrated ability but I think it's
essential when you want to win some
games
we should always remember that chess is
a two-player game and it's not only us
who's playing and our opponents always
want to do something at the same time so
let's start with the first example this
is my game against Alexander donchenko
it was played in 2009 so that was in the
world youth it's quite an old game
I was
11 years old at that time so it's it's
an old game but this definitely is one
of the the important games I played on
this topic so let's get started E4 D6 D4
Knight F6 Knight C3 G6
H3 so the reason I started I was playing
this line with H3 was actually quite
straightforward
um
the most common moves include the
simplest Knight to F3 but for some
reason I wanted to prevent my opponent
from playing Bishop G4 and taking the
Knight so I started applying this
prophylaxis Concept in a very early on
in the game it's of course not
necessarily the best line but I just
want to give you a feel of what it means
in in this position for example after I
played Knight F3 my opponent can no
longer
um Play Bishop G4 once again you're not
necessarily supposed to stop every
single move of your opponent but just to
get an idea of how it works let's try to
start it off from the very beginning of
the game just so that we get a good
sense of how things work Bishop G7
Bishop E2
short castles short castles and hear my
opponent played this move Knight bd7 so
black is trying to play this move E5
and control the center
it's very difficult to stop this push in
reality but I at least gave it a shot so
I'm developing a piece
to F4 while also preventing E5 so if my
opponent plays E5 I'm not really
completely preventing it I would say
because after it takes my opponent can
technically play this move Knight H5
attacking the bishop
and then regaining the pawn but at least
I am making his task a little bit more
difficult and it's maybe not so obvious
for them to play
so they played this move 98.
they are potentially threatening E5 but
here I played Queen D2
so it doesn't look like I'm preventing
E5 right or am I can anyone tell me am I
actually preventing E5 or
um
did I just allow my opponent to play the
movie five
so
what would happen if Black Goes E5 here
I'm looking at the chat at the same time
in person
so it looks like I'm not preventing it
because he has one two three Defenders
and I have
um and the pawn itself and I have three
attackers so but what happens after E5
is
I can simply just take
so it's still not so obvious right yeah
in the chat they're saying the queen is
undefended which is exactly the point
actually I can take this pawn and
although it looks like black can take me
in reality cannot because his Queen is
hanging
on d8 so I'm basically setting up a
small trap
pretending like I'm not allowing I'm
allowing him to play this move E5 that
he was trying to do but in reality
he cannot so I'm still improving my
pieces slowly while they're not doing
much
so here they played Queen C7 this time
they really want to play E5 because now
the queen is no longer hanging on this
Square
and here I played this move Bishop G5 so
I'm telling them you can actually play
E5 if you would like to but now this
would fail to Bishop E7 trap in Europe
so I'm making it harder and harder for
them to achieve this even very subtle
Pawn push into the center and it's
already annoying from the very start
and they get Knight to F6 this time they
want to go on E5 again at this point
it's impossible for me to stop it so I
just calmly improve my pieces just bring
them into the center and just let them
have the E5 push they want so they
prepared it with Rook E8 I played Rook
E1 and they finally played the move
E5 so at this point all my pieces are
developed
and I need to sort of come up with a
plan first of all I can take on an E5 I
can stay without doing anything I can
play something like A4 maybe just to
make a move or I can play the move D5 so
this is a very important moment I would
say in the game of what we should be
playing do we take on E5 do we go D5 or
do we go A4
so let's try to
let's try to come up with an idea here
and I think they all have potentially
their own advantages it's probably a
matter of choice rather than
absolute correctness but I will
definitely be thinking that the move I
played is
is the best move
so any suggestions
can be
A4 yeah A4 is definitely a good move
it's gaining some space
um
and potentially just preventing this
move B5 right it's just pretty good so I
think A4 is good probably my opponent
would
I don't know you I don't know what he
would play of course it's been a it's
been like 14 years but what's the idea
if it takes here
and he wants to take here right
so if I take what the knights I have to
be careful about this idea because after
he takes it takes
I mean I would still argue that we have
quite some compensation because his King
is open but I'm down upon and my knight
is also hanging so I need to do
something urgently and if I can't really
prove what I have I just lost the pawn
for nothing and also if I take with the
queen however now look at that he has a
bishop targeting my queen so I in
reality I don't prevent Knight E4
so I suddenly ended up in some chaos
which I don't really want to do because
I mean as the as playing with the white
pieces we really don't want to end up in
a situation like this where I'm down
upon and I have to sort things out
so that kind of brought me down yeah
D5 so that brings us to D5 and D E5 and
we have D5 as a suggestion why D5 over D
takes E5
um because
I feel like um
if we can keep the attention in the
center and possibly maybe have that for
later okay so if we keep the tension in
the center maybe we want to go F4 at
some point and also we're actually
threatening to Simply take take and take
on D6 right so if I were to go D takes
E5 D takes E5 I would actually trade the
pawns on D4 with the pawn on D6
essentially that's what we're doing
because this Pawn left the board that
pawn left the board they all met on E5
so I don't want to do that because he's
D6 Pawn is actually a potential weakness
that I would like to try to take
advantage of at some point there is
actually a very common idea to try to
trade Queens but
whenever you trade Queens in these types
of positions although this is definitely
better for white slightly better for
white I would ideally like to keep more
pieces on the board because whenever you
have more space you should try to have
more pieces on the board and on the
other side if you have less space you
should try to trade as many pieces as
you can which is one of from one of the
games we saw in the yesterday stream so
I don't want to do that although in this
position it kind of looks tough for
black to untangle their pieces because
there's a pressure on F6 but even in
this situation they can play something
like Knight H5 try to go F6 to kick this
bishop out they can try to go Bishop f8
to kick the Rook out and then start
untangling somehow with maybe Knight C5
Bishop E6 and this is not something I
would like to allow
so in this position I actually did play
the move
D5
and if my opponent doesn't want to allow
the position to open up
so they can play the move C5 and if they
take on D5 this is what they would
probably face takes takes takes and if
you take with the queen now I can try to
start putting pressure here by
some ideas like Bishop to C4
I also have the D6 Pawn hanging for free
so there's all sorts of opportunities I
can go Rook D2 first cover up my second
Rank and the idea of prophylaxis so I
defend this guy and then maybe take on
D6 so we got a little bit of everything
in this position
okay so we're not allowing our opponent
to open the center and we're developing
our pieces so opponent goes here the
move C5 okay so now what do we do
how can I improve my position and just
try to limit my opponent from doing
whatever they want it's very important
whenever you are trying to do what you
want
this thinking mechanism of prophylaxis
stopping your opponent's play should
always be at the back of your mind it
can be tactically it can be positionally
it doesn't matter so if you were playing
with the black pieces how would you try
to
continue this game well if I was playing
Black I know I would try to put pressure
with A6 B5 B4 try to put pressure on
this Knight so that I can win the pawn
on e4
okay it's kind of easy to figure out so
how about I play something like A4 now I
just prevented my opponent's B5 push
probably for the next at least five six
moves because for them to be able to
play B5 successfully they need to go A6
probably Rook B8 and they need a lot
more help to try to go B5 because I'm
actually guarding it with three pieces
at this point
so now black is on the back foot they're
completely passive they need to do
something because it's not easy to just
sit and wait and not do anything in
chess so my opponent goes A6 he's
getting ready and then
this is actually an important position
in my opinion so what would you play
with white here
how would you try to improve like it's
not just stopping opponents from what
they want to do
like whenever we see a puzzle it's kind
of easy because they tell us like it's
white to play and win black to play and
win and like it's very straightforward
but what do you do in a position like
this where optically speaking all your
pieces are doing fantastic but you're
not quite sure how to win and of
restricting your opponent to a certain
point is great but it doesn't just win
the game so how do we make progress
while limiting our opponent is kind of
the idea and this position
what would anyone play with white here
and with what idea preferably
okay we have a rook A1 suggestion
well we just played The Rook from A1 to
D1 and then now we want to go back
what's the idea of Rook A1 there's
Bishop H6 as a suggestion yeah
Knight H2 is another suggestion
okay and then we want to try to go like
F4 stuff so you want to build an attack
on the king side
okay that's a that's a pretty good idea
too only idea I can come up with is move
our Queen side pawns okay we have some
Queen side expansion suggestions so we
got multiple ideas in this in this
situation where it's not so clear where
we want to put our pieces we have some
Knight H2 to G4 maybe generate something
on the king side which I absolutely like
we have Bishop H6
trying to go
um
trying to go maybe trade the Bishops and
then do something and then we got other
ideas like try to play B4 at some point
I'm not sure exactly how but try to
figure it out and then there is an idea
of Rook A1 being suggested to prevent
the idea of B5 although we don't
necessarily need it right now that is uh
that is definitely something to keep in
mind so here I actually played the move
Queen E3
the reason I did that is in this Pawn
structure
the one I'm just highlighting the idea
of putting the knights on C4 is actually
a very
common one so Knight D2 Knight C4 is
um
what my main
idea is so I played Queen E3 and at the
same time I'm preventing my opponent
from still playing the move H6 so they
never get any counter play on The Queen
side so they play Knight f8 they're
trying to move around their pieces
they're trying to go Bishop D7 Rook B8
and then maybe B5 so that's what they're
currently working on and I played this
move Knight D2 so how is Knight D2 even
responding towards
sorry B5 the idea is that if you play
this move
Bishop D7
you're trying to do something like that
well I don't want to kind of give any
spoilers so I'm not gonna reveal the
move exactly right now but there is a
nice idea coming up soon to prevent the
move B5 although it was kind of
suggested before so here my opponents
instead played the Knight to D7 trying
to do some push push maybe bring the
Knight they want to attack me on the
king side bring this Knight to F4 so
they're kind of trying to develop
something on the king side I just go
Bishop D3 I prevent him from playing F5
now so that's also another key idea in
the king's Indian they always want to go
F5 F4 all these attacking ideas which I
don't want to deal with by any means so
I play Bishop D3 so that you can never
ever play F5
so I'm preventing a lot of things
while improving my pieces so now they go
Rook to B8 in this position and actually
it's very smart what they're doing
because if they allowed me I was going
to put my knight on C4 and then I was
going to play the move A5 and restrict
this B5 push forever because I would
have a takes B6 ample sound so what they
did with Rook B8 is if I ever play
Knight C4 now they can go B5 so my
opponent is preventing my play because I
cannot allow the pawn to go to B5 this
was a classical game yes
so what do I do now is the is a very
important question I would say
and this is actually the the key moment
of the game
which I think the tables turned big time
so this idea was mentioned in the chat
before so it kind of
um
was already said before but it's it's
quite nice it's quite a creative idea
and considering I was quite young and
finding this idea I was actually very
happy about things
so
white to play here
and of course we need a very concrete
idea why are we trying to why are we
doing what we're doing
any ideas
yeah so what was our idea before what
were we trying to achieve we're trying
to achieve him not playing B5 and how
are we trying to achieve not not
allowing opponents yeah the chat is
right and how are we stop planning to
stop this B5 push our idea was put the
Knight on C4 with the idea to play A5
but I can't do that because after I play
this they get B5 immediately so I need
to support this A5 push somehow and
that's exactly when the move Rook A1
comes into play so my Rook was doing
absolutely nothing and for me to be able
to play my Pawn to A5 I actually have to
relocate a centralized Rook back to its
original place which is kind of unique I
would say because not every day you see
a move Rook on D1 going to A1 in order
to play the pawn to A5
and actually when you look at this with
an engine the engine also supports the
Rook A1 with the idea to play A5 so
that's kind of what happened in the game
um he did he did play the move B6 he
doesn't want me to play A5 I played
Queen E2 attacking this Pawn of course
if you ever play the move A5 this
position will just collapse instantly
with the Knight coming to B5 so he
cannot do that had to play something
like Rook A8 and now I finally managed
to get my knight on C4 which I have been
trying to do in the last couple of
months so we achieved a lot of things
um in just a few moves
opponent goes H6 and I just Retreat I do
not have any business on that square
anymore so I leave and here my opponent
plays the move G5 so we achieved a lot
of things right we achieved that my
opponent wants to do stuff on the
we stopped everything on the queen side
and now I have to deal with
my opponent trying to do some things in
the king side so that's clearly what
they're building and I don't want to get
checkmated so I need to react
accordingly towards my opponent's plan
okay so what can we do here
how do I stop my opponent's king side
business
while creating stuff for myself
the last thing I want him to do is
um is allow him to attack me so why it
is better having more space and activity
that's correct white is definitely
better with more space and activity
but how do we utilize that space and
activity because close positions
are sometimes good for King side attacks
or flank attacks let's say so that's
what they're trying to do they want to
do something so one suggestion is G3
but the moment I play G3 I'm kind of
weakening this Square although maybe my
opponent can't take advantage of it I
would still be a little bit more
hesitant towards playing move like G3
because now my opponent suddenly gets
some chances on this diagonal so ideally
speaking I would like to do something
else
at least
in my mind
but what's also a drawback of G5 yeah
Queen D2 to go Knight E2 so we are
trying to do stuff like that with the
idea of what why are we bringing the
Knight
and then
that's fantastic so the idea of Queen D2
would be try to bring the Knight to a
weakened Square so that's exactly the
answer of what what was wrong with G5 is
that it completely vacates the F5 square
and now I can try to utilize this square
with this Knight on C3 but the question
is how do I even do that first of all
yes I can do this queen D2 idea but
ideally speaking I would like to do
something a little bit more energetic
because as my opponent just opened up
with G5 now their King side is going to
be slightly weak so I actually played
this move H4 so the idea is very similar
I am still preventing his Knight G6
business but I also want to just open up
his King because he played G5 so we're
not just dealing with the positional
aspect of things we're trying to play it
also as dynamically as possible trying
to open up his King so I played Queen H5
here I'm attacking this guy and that guy
if he plays Knight G6 or something
I can definitely take here and if you
play Knight F6 I can try to hold on to
my bishop and I'll be equalizing the
pawns and probably having a good
position overall so my opponent played
Knight F6 I took they played Knight G6
attacking my queen I go here I attack I
go back and then they go here okay so
it's white to play now what would white
play here
we did some shuffling back and forth but
we got
um
we got the position
somewhat under control but we need to
figure out a move now
what would you play with white
this is another
I would say not so complicated move
so Raymond is suggesting F3 and Alex is
suggesting Bishop H6 so we got two
suggestions here one of them is right
the other one is wrong
who's going to tell me why one of his
one of Islam is right and the other one
is wrong
yeah anyone
if Bishop takes H6 black can just go in
ig4 so which one is the right move then
F3 so what's the idea of F3
exactly so we're tactically blocking
this Knight G4 idea
we're strengthening our Pawn structure
to
we're using tactics and now we're
threatening this Pawn
so here my opponent played H5
I played Bishop to G5
and here my opponent played
um Bishop D7
okay so we got some some opportunities
here and here I decided to go A5 I tried
to just make some progress on the other
flank too
uh
a couple of Trades I'll just go a little
fast on this one Rook A1 I'm attacking
the pawn on A6 my opponent defense all
right so now this is also an important
moment I would say it is white to play
what would you do with white
foreign
to get greedy by taking here
but I don't think greed is good because
we suddenly gave up the pair of Bishops
and I feel like this might benefit my
opponent they can try to go something
like King G7 try to get this bishop out
Bring The Rook in and go Knight F4 or
maybe bring the bishop here I'm not sure
and they will try to get some counter
play and in reality I don't really want
them to get any counter play by just
going for one Pawn so
these types of situations I usually try
not to take on F6
or give up the pair of Bishops just for
the sake of getting a pawn because our
advantage is actually way bigger than
just winning upon
so here I played something
that I honestly think is
very underestimated
I played this move B3 and the reason
this move is underestimated is it looks
like I'm just doing nothing but in
reality I'm just being super patient
with my position I am absolutely in no
rush
to try to win the game
I'm just moving my pieces and improving
them and I'm just slowly making sure my
opponent never ever gets any counter
play on any Square so instead of my Pawn
being loose on B2 I actually make sure
that it's guarded by a Pawn on C2 that
is guarded by a bishop so everyone is
like defending each other which allows
this Knight to be actually free at this
point so now if I feel like moving this
Knight I can actually freely move it to
try to maybe go to F5 and I don't have
to worry about upon hanging on B2 out of
nowhere so this is kind of
underestimated play because
moves like this they seem like they are
very simple and harmless but actually
they're very effective as they restrict
your opponent more and more because they
have no space in this situation my
opponent played Bishop B7 and as we
earlier talked talked about this F5
square is weak so I can definitely route
one of my Knights onto that square but
the question is which Knight do I take
to F5 do I move the Knight on C4 or do I
move the Knight on C3
which one is the right Knight to take to
F5
any preference
C3 right
because the Knight on C4 is actually
doing great right it's putting pressure
here but the Knight on C3 isn't doing
much so we go Knight E2 with the idea to
go here and plus I might actually win
this Pawn too while I'm traveling to F5
so my opponent actually tried to run
away and then they actually had to go
back because the Knight on F5 would be
way too powerful and now I simply grab
the pawn so in reality I did end up
winning the opponent on H5 but I didn't
have to give up my dark squared Bishop
for
for the night just yet and here my
opponent plays Knight E5 Knight F4 sorry
he's threatening my queen
also my Bishop
and if I move the queen somewhere he's
probably gonna take my bishop and take
on B3
so I don't really want to deal with any
of that so I take the Knight and we get
into a position like this so it's white
to play what do we do
he's attacking our Rock
we can move the Rook
but we have to be careful with where we
move the Rook
we shouldn't be moving it
to somewhere that's not
great
one bad example would be although this
probably still wins is an example like
this which would
which would be sad but probably my
position is still good because his
pieces are just not doing anything so I
think I would still be able to win this
position even in a situation like this
plus I have some activity there which
we're probably not thinking about at the
moment but there is no need here I just
played Rook D1 not blundering anything
E5 would have also been interesting and
I just played E5 on the next move
so now I have
all sorts of active pieces on the board
yeah I could have played E5 on the
previous go I just preferred it like
this to have this Rook also maybe doing
something my opponent took this guy and
then I played D6 so now I'm further
pushing him
to the back foot and then
it's time to kind of wrap it up I took
the spawn and it's funny about this Rook
the journey actually began with Rook D1
and then I went back to A1 went to A5
went to C5 and
the journey will still continue my
opponent played this Rook went to C7 I'm
actually further going in with the rook
and then he goes
Rook C8
and then anyone wants to guess the move
it's probably easy yeah
Knight B6
my B6 but then I can take the Rook
and then D to xc7 your idea is perfect
if I take here you take there but we
always have to be alert
for tactics
they're always in there they're hiding
so we shouldn't be rushing the the
winning ideas here so another guess
maybe
that was a nice idea though
so The Rook went there and then went
there went here went there went there
how about we go further
foreign
Rook E7 I was just to the heart of the
position just bringing my Rook from A1
to E7 just like that just moving around
my opponent played Rook C5 I just want
to trade the Bishops that's that's a
bluff of course the moment you take here
it's going to be made on F7
so he played E4 trying to create some
counter play I just take it's a free
Pawn goes Queen C8 and I play E5 so I
still can't take it the bishop is
poisoned because there's mate
and my opponent sacrificed some pieces
they're trying to do some stuff but
they're not going to get out of it all
right Queen takes E5 it's not so easy
actually suddenly there's a Chaos on the
board and maybe I'm not winning maybe of
course I am but
you never know so it's white to play how
do I get rid of this mess my opponent is
threatening Queen takes F5
how do I tactically avoid losing a
bishop
how do I prevent that Queen F5 idea
we need to use our tactical senses to
prevent
foreign
I see this guy is hanging
yeah
perfect
Queen F3
so now I'm utilizing that
he goes there I take he takes and then
we play a couple moves
and eventually I promote this point
actually I think he got checkmated
let me see yeah he did get checkmate
I'm done okay
so this was one example this was a bit
on the sophisticated end it's not like
too simple but opponent couldn't do
anything there was Zero threads towards
my king I don't remember him ever giving
me a check it was just a very simple
play
okay so that was good but let's see
let's see another example where
um
I think I messed up everything in the
opening and then I was completely losing
and then I somehow managed to get out of
it but we're gonna see why and how all
right so I'm playing with the white
pieces I played the London because
I always played the London when I don't
know what to do so my opponent goes D5 I
go E3 this is the jababa London so it's
not a
um
he could give some check though before
getting mated he could have given a
check yeah he could have
so and then I played H4 so this is this
is my line I like to like not my line of
course it's it's a line I like to play
for a win and it's a lot of it's a lot
of fun the main idea just to show it is
if black castles here we go H5 and if
Knight H5 I like to sacrifice here and
there's a ton of theory but this is a
lot of fun and I like playing checks
like this if you know how I play this is
the way I play at this point in my life
my opponent goes C5 I go Knight B5 I'm
threatening fourcon C7 he has to react
and then I just start developing my
pieces so everything looks looks normal
right there is nothing
nothing too bad and I'm like okay I
wanna I wanna go H5 so bad that I'm not
even like counseling or anything so
and my opponent is like okay I don't see
your ideas I'm just gonna go win your
Pawn very simple
to me I thought this was
gonna be a very straightforward win
because in my understanding if I have a
huge attack happening
I thought this should be like
nothing to discuss so I just played G4
I'm like going all in
and
okay so he just plays Knight D7 I'm like
okay I mean the Knight on F6 just left
the square so
the attack should be much more easier
and I play this move G5 I'm a little bit
careless I would say I'm just pushing my
king side pawns but I don't really have
a true follow-up
behind behind what I'm doing so he goes
Knight E5 I take and then he goes Knight
C7 so his idea is to kind of defend
everything with this move 96 so
therefore I played
Bishop G4 I'm preventing him from going
to easy with Knight E6 so but he still
goes it's not like I truly stop them
and then I take on G6 he takes their
and I I evaluate I'm like if I take here
he just takes back and if I try to go
something like Queen G4 well he's never
ever gonna allow me to do anything and
if I even get a check on H7
well that's not gonna help me achieve
anything
so my idea was okay let me at least try
to do something on
D5 Square potentially Castle log maybe
do something on D5 maybe double up on
the H file try to get something going
right so he goes Queen B6
he's attacking my Pawn on B2
I play Queen H3 I'm threatening some
mate so it looks quite scary
how should black prevent this well he
just moves The Rook simple enough
and then I cast along
kind of looks that kind of looks
tempting too
and then my opponent goes Knight there
okay so why to play how do we even try
to go forward here what's what's
something I can try to even create
in the situation
I mean it doesn't look like I have a
real Attack happening
and whereas even prophylaxis going to
come into play so E6 is a suggestion but
if I play E6
so this guy is hanging
this would not be good I don't want that
because if I go there
let's see what's the if there's a mate
here let's try to figure it out
hmm
well at least there is this right
let me go here
okay it looks like you're still alive
somehow
you're still not mated takes
still not made it but also
you might be made it very soon yeah
he takes F7
let me slide the king
scary
it's very scary for both sides
but the game is still on and I'm
threatening mate right now
oh no definitely not that
was a slip
but
I don't see
I don't see I think E6 is dangerous
I like the idea though but I think it's
dangerous what else
anyways I just played the movie cage too
that's why not
all right the main question is actually
the black to play so that's the main
main question what would you do here
with black
this is where the prophylaxis and
Dynamics come into play
now that I look at it it's very easy I
actually thought it was super easy in
the game too and believe it or not if
you if my opponent played a couple
correct moves I was ready to resign
because
I just gave up all my pieces with white
and I'm about to get checkmated too
my king is weak not only his King is in
danger my king is in danger so Knight A4
is the suggestion
so they want to attack the pawn on B2
and I'll give you a hint
um
yeah the other Alex says I think black
should attack so everyone is saying
black should attack well Rook ac8 would
kind of be unfortunate because I have a
bishop there right
so that wouldn't really help
so everyone is like okay I think black
should attack Knight A4 Rook CA do
something on the king side
yeah
so E6 is another suggestion to give
blacks King to some Escape Square okay
okay
E6 so why E6 you want to run away with
the King but what's the what's the
danger
what are we afraid of
are we afraid of anything specific or is
just the just in case yeah
and then
exactly
and that would just end the game right
so here my opponent just like the chat
they were like okay I'm just gonna go
Knight A4 I'm gonna attack the B2 pawn
and then they lost the game very quickly
but instead if they've played the movie
E6 I have nothing left in the position
because I would have played something
like this in next move
what would you play here okay
and now the king escapes so just because
the move E6 is no longer attacking it
doesn't mean it's actually
not useful so moves like this very very
undervalued E6 was just enough for black
to win the game because after they
played Knight A4 I did play this just to
get an idea A5 was also suggested but I
would like to show what White's idea is
I was going to play Rook H1
and if you continue doing something I'm
actually threatening Queen AJ check
sacrificing my queen and then Rook H7
Checkmate so that's my idea and
therefore black actually had to play E6
with the idea to run away and how can
you do that well you have to first ask
yourself what does my opponent want
if my opponent saw my Rook H1 Queen h8
idea they would have absolutely played
this and then they would have won the
game in almost no time but
because they hurried up and they played
Knight A4 they completely overlooked my
Rook H1 idea because they believed that
their attack is stronger than my attack
but
unfortunately it's not they played at
five I took on F6 on poissant they took
here okay now what
how do we win the game with white
it's not too difficult
should be fairly easy
yeah same mate
but what happens if he goes here
exactly it's like the queen takes
Rook check
and then
it's the power of the Bishops right
I prevent everything
and that's me
this was another
um
another nice one all right so I want to
do one specific position from
a very recent game I played I played
this game in the
2022 Olympiad in Chennai against
a Polish Grandmaster
Miranda he's 26-36 rated and I'll just
go to the key moment I would say I'm
gonna go fast forward
all the way it's another another crazy
game with me attacking on the king side
I'm kind of gonna skip the theory part
of it maybe I'll show it in a different
day but it's a lot of craziness
happening in this game
um
and here my opponent played Rook h8 so
I would like to stop at this moment and
then
try to guess to try to find the move
here with
with the white pieces and this is
essentially the the Dynamics in
prophylaxis so I would say this is where
you kind of get the the fruits of like
your training is in the moments like
this playing in the Olympiad
representing my country
um
and position is somewhat equal I would
say roughly equal maybe slightly
favoring the black pieces but
it's a very tough position I would say
so
black just played rook h8 and we kind of
have to figure out
how can we
do something about it
so
the floor is
the chats and everyone else's
it's white to play
it's a fairly complicated position I
would say because it's very rare that
you get these like weird tripled Pawns
in the middle one very quick question is
in the chat why not take the bishop well
the problem is if I take the bishop
they're going to capture my Rook first
and after I capture The Rook they're
gonna take this bishop and I can't touch
that pawn due to the pin and after they
go F5 I'm actually not very happy
because then they get a lot of Pawns two
connected passers not even sure if this
is two or three because they have
another one in the back so
that's that's quite annoying and I
really don't want to deal with this pin
um
because if I even try to do something
like this with the idea of taking the
pawn they actually can reinforce these
pawns and potentially trade the queens
or bring the knight in just looks very
bad so we cannot
capture
the bishop
all right one suggestion is B4
all right so what's the idea of B4
that's an interesting move
so what does B4 do I guess B4 is
preventing the move C5 right that's kind
of the idea I would say
which is
conceptually
um
I would say very deep
but it looks like a good move
okay what else
I guess the main question to ask is if
you were playing with the black pieces
now if it was your move
what would you play
yeah
so if you were black you would play
Queen F4
right and if I take
Knight takes okay and then you have a
pin here right
very good and how would white try to
deal with that
where King B1
King B1 now
or
after Knight F4
okay so suggestion is King B1 now and
how does King B1 prevent Queen F4
Queen G2 okay so if I go Queen G2
can I
can I do that
Maybe
it's not even clear I can also take
Rook takes
possible I guess
do I have anything else
so King B1 now is also in the chat so I
think that's a preferred move
which I think is is an interesting move
any suggestions for black here what do
you what do we do here actually let's
quickly answer that
foreign
I mean I can definitely go Rook G4
or Rook E8 is another suggestion which I
actually like
this also looks very tempting
but what happens if I take is their mate
I don't see if there's mate
takes takes check
here it's chaos on board again I don't
think there's mate here
yeah probably there is no meat here so
let's not go in there
although although one second one second
there is check here
because you can't block what the queen
there's Queen takes G4
you can't go there it's mate so you have
to go on a journey
you go on a journey with there's no way
you're gonna escape this
actually
so that's a made idea but the king can
run away right
so how about I do something like this
I wasn't expecting this chaos but then
there's maybe D5
preventing this attacking that
well this is not what I was thinking
from this game
Queen F5 was also a check yeah this game
is a
is a chaos maybe this is good but
that looks very messy
too messy for my taste
um and also we couldn't really address
the question Knight H4 because if I go
Rook G4 fg4 Queen G4 I'm still down
down upon right
and he can Retreat to defend
Messi is good he's good okay so
that didn't quite solve my problems
can be one
but what else can we do here
why is King B1 even uh
prophylaxis move it stops Queen F4 check
but it's not really stopping
the idea of Queen F4 right so Bishop F1
is being suggested I'm gonna guess that
you're suggesting Bishop F1 here
but Bishop F4 Bishop F1 also it doesn't
it actually loses a piece immediately
check and then takes
so
this would lose pretty much on the spot
unfortunately
it doesn't work
so yeah I mean it's a pretty tough
position I did end up playing King B1
but we need to understand why so why is
this King B1 so strong
Queen F4
and I'll show the answer it's actually
a little unexpected how this King B1
plays a role it looks like the idea was
to get out of check
but the question is with check well this
is how the game went I take on G4 my
opponent took here I took on here with
check they played King f8 and then I
played Bishop D7 who's gonna tell me
what would have happened if my king was
on C1 yeah
yeah 92. so if my king was here Knight
E2 would have forked my king and the
rook and therefore after seeing that in
advance I played my king to B1 sort of
setting a trap to get to this position
because now I can take on C6 or B5
whatever he gives or C5
and this would
this actually helped me to collect some
points one question in chat did you have
Bishop F3 well I potentially did have
Bishop F3 but I saw that I can win this
pawn and that pawn so I was like might
as well collect everything instead of
collecting one thing so I played King B1
and then I'll just show the rest of the
game really quickly
um
I played this King there I took on C6 he
played here
I played A4 kind of
getting myself two passers
in the center
opponent blade 96 they really want to
push the F Pawn down the board I pin him
I'm threatening to go D5 there you go
King D6 they wanna go F5
so what do I do
I play Rook F3 I prevent them from
playing F5 they go King E7 and then now
I finally bring my Rook into the action
I want to win this Pawn
they try to go
and create some counter play but I
eventually gang up on this Pawn
there and I just push the ball
D5
and D6 and that's it and that's resigns
because after that okay what's the
easiest way to win in this position
it's quite simple I would say yeah
D7
and if King takes of course you just
take here and then take the Knight
and if King E7
wrote These six King d8
some
absolutely end up here
good job and that's what I win the game
so my opponents resigned I think here
and that was it but the critical the
most critical moment of this game is
King B1
I'm not saying that King B1 wins the
game by any means
um
don't get me wrong the position is still
super unclear but the idea is to
actually prevent my opponent's Queen F4
I think he should have played the move
C5 which I don't truly like remember
what my response was going to be
um it's been a couple of months at this
point probably I didn't have like the
smartest response in mind at that point
but I would have figured something out
maybe
maybe I just go like A3 or something try
to
just live basically but
I think C5 was the best move of course I
can't take because there's Queen D1 mate
but at least I dodged the queen F4
Bullet by
preventing them from playing Knight E2
all the way at the end of the line
and yeah this bishop is also guarding
the H1 square if needed and so on
a question on the chat what was your
highest rating opponent beaten
26.70 I think I think 2670 that should
be
it was a Russian Grandmaster in our Kiev
I've shown that game also in one of the
previous Grand Master's Choice lectures
in
December
so yeah this was the last game I had in
mind King B1 was definitely not easy
we're probably gonna be doing a lot of
like in the grand Master's Choice a lot
of Dynamics tactics prophylaxis and so
on so my style of Chess is avoiding my
opponent's play a lot while I'm
attacking them so I have a lot of
attacking games this was kind of like a
warm-up introductory uh
session to the topic we're going to be
seeing a lot more
um
in the future and final question in chat
how do you think tournament Players
should approach the opening
it's kind of there is a lot of
there is a lot of openings
um to learn so I guess you can pick them
up by playing if you can study them
there's a lot of approaches you can take
so I don't think there's one concrete
approach in terms of opening
but
yeah
thank you guys for watching
um
and I guess I'll see you all next time
bye-bye
[Music]